Merhabalar
bu enstrümanı bilen kaç kişi var
Aramızda
bayağı varmış
benim için gelenler belli oldu
[Kahkaha]
Bu bir İran enstrümanı ervane deft
ediyorlar
Benim Hikayem bu enstrümanla başladı bu
hayatın bana sunduğu bir hediye
Biz yurt dışına ettik müzik aletleri
satışı yapıyoruz enstrüman satışı
yapmadığımız ülke neredeyse kalmadı
Amerika'dan
somali'ye kadar birçok ülkeye satış
yaptık ve yapıyoruz Ben herhangi bir
enstrüman çalmıyorum
konservatuarda okumadım Hatta sesim bile
çok kötü peki peki
enstrümanların bu büyülü dünyasına ve
nasıl girdim size biraz bundan
bahsedeceğim
üniversitedeyken çok sevdiğim bir kız
vardı fakat kız beni sevmiyordu
Ben de bunu etkilemek için elimden gelen
her şeyi yapıyordum ama her şeyi
kızın doğum günü yaklaşıyordu ben de
bunu bir fırsata dönüştürmek istedim kız
müzikle ilgiliydi bana az önce
bahsettiğim enstrümanı almak istedim
enstrüman deyince aklına ilk gelen
yerlerden biri olan Taksim'e gittim
yoktu un kapağına gittim yoktu
internette araştırdım yine bulamadım Bir
ara bir muhabbette bir arkadaşım dedi ki
bana bu bir araştırma dedi dedi sen bunu
İran'dan getirtebilirsin Ben de Hakkari
yüksek olayım İran'dan bir şeyler
getirmek benim için çok kolay hemen
sınırdayız
Yüksekova'da bir arkadaşı aradım Dedim
ki böyle bir ürün var getirir misin
Tabii ki getiririm dedi benim bir aydır
arayıp bulamadığım enstrümanı çocuk bana
5-6 günde getirtmiştim
Hemen paketi aldım heyecanla eve gittim
Paketi açtım içinden çıkan ürüne
inanamadım bir enstrüman ama tablo gibi
dedim ya mutlaka benim durumumda olan
başkaları da vardır
Bizim evde çirkin bir kanepe vardı onun
üstüne koydum bir fotoğrafını çektim
amazon'a yükledim fotoğrafı da öptüm
koltuk görünmesin
e-ticarette görsel satıyor biliyorsunuz
daha sonra heyecanla Hemen paketi Defi
paketleyip kızla görüşmeye gittim Bir
dakika daha bekleyemezdim evde kızın
yanına gittim Defi verdim kendisine O da
çok beğendi hayran kalmıştı ayağa kalktı
sarıldı bana
fırsattan istifada Ben de sarıldım
hayatımda hiç o kadar mutlu olduğumu
hatırlamıyorum
hiçbir şey beni bu kadar mutlu edemezdi
Leyla'ya dönmüştüm ya da Mecnun muydu
neyse ne oynamıyor cinsiyet ayrımına
Hayır
[Alkış]
eve giderken otobüste Kız daha benimle
sevgili olmayı kabul etmemişken ben
onunla evlilik hayalleri kuruyordum
şarkılar söylüyordum o güzel sesimle
Otobüsten indim Eve doğru yürüyordum
bizim evin bulunduğu apartmanın önüne
geldim
telefonumu wifi Evin internetine
bağlandı amazon'dan e-mail geldi bana
ürünü satıldı
6 aydır Amazon'da Mahmut tahtakale'den
fotoğrafını çekip yayınlamadığım ürün
kalmamıştı patates dilimleme
makinesinden tıraş köpüğü sabununa kadar
hiçbiri satılmamış ama 3 saat önce
yayınladığım ürün satılmıştı
bir günde hem aşkı kazanmıştım Hem
parayı
hiçbir şeyin beni kız arkadaşım bana
sarılmasına daha çok mutlu etmeyeceğini
zannediyordum O Yanılmışım başka şeyler
de varmış
5 dakika önce leyla'ydım şimdi gözlerim
için vereceğim
fakat bir sorun vardı ervane yoktu çünkü
hediye olarak vermiştim Amazon'da da bir
ürünü 2-3 gün içinde kargolamazsanız
hesabınız kapatılıyor aynı ürünü istesem
5-6 gün sürüyor
bir anda büyük bir duygu değişimine
girdim
Çok mutluyken çok stresli bir hale
gittim
akşam düşünceli bir şekilde uyudum Sabah
uyandım zaten uyuyamamıştım
Dersim olmamasına rağmen okula gittim
Bir öğrenci düşünün dersi yok ama okula
gidiyor
mesaj attım görüşebilir miyiz diye
görüşelim dedi ben hemen kantine Gittim
onu bekledim kız geldi Bir baktım
arabayla birlikte geliyor bir an çok
umutlandım dedim ki büyük ihtimalle bu
kız diyecek ki bana
senin duygularınla oynamak istemiyorum
Sen sana umut vermek istemiyorum O
yüzden bu hediye kabul edemem
bana geri verir Ben de kabul eder alırım
hemen müşteriye kargoları
ama yanılmışım öyle değilmiş Kız hediye
çok beğendiği için arkadaşlarına
göstermek için getirmiş Okulu
eşim daha da zorlaşmıştı
bir an Benjamin Franklin ağır bastı
derin bir nefes aldım
bütün cesaretimi topladım kıza durumu
anlattım dedim ki ben bu ürünü sattım
geriye almam gerekiyor
kız ayağa kalktı eğer bana el masanın
üstüne koydu 2 saniye gözlerimin içine
baktı hiçbir şey söylemeden gitti
o iki saniyelik bakışta lügatındaki
bütün küfürleri bana ettiğini adım gibi
eminim onun adı salak manyak gibi
küfürlerdir hep Birlik küfürler
baktım kız gözden uzaklaşıyor dedim ya
zaten kızı kaybettik bari müşteri
kaybetmeyelim aldım
Aldım
ervaneyi kargoya verdim sonra aynısından
iki tane istedim
birisini satmak için diğerini hediye
vermek için ama ikisi gelmeden satıldı
daha sonra 4 tane istedim Sonra 8 hep 2
katlayarak gidiyordum Bir gün bir
müşteriden e-mail aldım bize bu ürünlere
ulaşılabilir kıldığın için sana
minnettarım diye başlıyordu Böyle bu tür
cümlelere Ben alışmıştım
bana neden minyatör olduklarını
anlamıyorum Bir yandan da gururlanıyorum
ve çaktırmamaya çalışıyorum Evet değerli
bir iş yapıyoruz falan diyorum
o e-mail de anlamıştım bana neden
minnettar olduklarını İran'dan
Amerika'ya İsrail'e ve birçok ülkeye
kargo göndermek yasak Swift vize Master
altyapısı yok Ödeme yapamıyorlar ben bu
ürünleri İran'dan alıp Türkiye'ye
getiriyorum Türkiye üzerinden bütün
dünya dağıtıyorum sanatı ve sanatçıya
katkıda
şunu yazıyordu
İran enstrümanı olan ervana satıyorsunuz
başka bir İran enstrümanı olan santrali
var mı diye sormuştu bana bizde dahile
geleneğidir hiçbir müşteriye yok
demiyoruz
Hatta Amcamın bir anısını anlatayım
amcamın marketi var Yüksekova'da
onun bu huyunu bilen bir müşterisi
gitmiş yanına demiş ki at nalı var mı
markette Adnan ne gezer amcam demiş ki
Bir dakika bekler misin depoya gitmiş
aramış 70 bulmuş gitmiş
Benim de aklıma hep o gelir amcam
markette Ben satır mı bulamayacağım
dedim Tabii ki var dedim yüksek
Yukarıdaki arkadaşı aradım Dedim ki
santrifü var dedi yolladı yine meşhur
kanepenin üstüne koydum bir fotoğrafını
çektim müşteriye yolladım müşteri kabul
etti Daha sonra yine erbanede yaptığım
gibi iki tane Santur istedim sonra 4
sonra 8 ikiye katlayarak gidiyorum şu an
turla beraber diğer enstrümanlarını
eklemeye başladım portföyümü
açığa Tamam bak gibi
Yine bir gün bir müşteriden e-mail aldım
hep müşterilerin Yönlendirmeleri ve
sipariş veriyorum
şöyle diyordu bana Türkiye'desin ama
İran enstrümanları satıyorsun neden
Türkiye enstrümanları yok demişti bana
Ben de hangisi dedim Dedi ki ut bizde de
biliyorsunuz aile geleneği yok demiyoruz
Tabii ki var dedim
hemen ot üzerine araştırma yaptım buldum
fotoğrafını yolladım ona kabul etti
mutlaka beraber diğer Türk müziği
gazetelerini eklemeye başladım
Ermeni müzik aletleri ekledim Azeri
müzik aletleri ekledim
her şey yolunda gidiyor Dünyada hiçbir
mağazada bulamayacağınız kadar çok
çeşitte enstrüman var elimde Ama hala
bir mağazam yok benim
mağaza açmayı Dere reddediyorum Çünkü
biliyorum ki eğer mağaza açarsam
özgürlüğüm kısıtlanacak o dükkana bağlı
kalacağım
rahatıma geliyor bir ara hatta bu hale
gelmiştik
3+1 yerde kalıyoruz 2 odası depo
salonda da 3 kişi yan yana yatıyoruz
Hayat beni zorluyor
Baskılar var üstünde birincisi anne baba
baskısı
para kazandığımı görüyor Anne Babam
memur değilim
herhangi bir iş yapmıyorum dükkanım yok
fakat nerede para kazandığımı
bilmiyorlar kötü yola düştüğümüz
zannediyorlar
ikincisi Bazen müşteri doğal olarak
enstrüman deneyerek almak istiyor Bende
mağaza Yok eve götürüyorum bir kanepeye
oturtuyorum enstrümanı deniyor
tam o dönerken ev arkadaşım donuyla
çıkıp banyoya girebiliyordu
Ben de çok zoruma gidiyordu Bu durum
artık baskılara dayanamayarak
Üsküdar'daki ilk mağazamı açtım
artık müşterilerim gururla karşılıyorum
herhangi birisi donuyla çıkacakmış gibi
korkusu yok yani artık
her şey yolunda gidiyor böyle Ticaret
iyi mağaza da iyi Fakat bunun böyle
devam etmeyeceğini farkındayım Çünkü
e-ticaret kolaylaşıyor hızlanıyor yerine
bugün rakiplerin girecek piyasaya benim
pastadan alacağım pay düşecek Ben de
bunun çözümünün markalaşma ile
olabileceğini biliyorum Eğer
markalaşırsam bir adım önde olacaktım
rakiplerin
o zaman marka üzerine kafayı bozdum
sürekli marka üzerine araştırmalar
eğitimler alıyorum işte o aralar Apple
var Steve Jobs var kendimiz Steve jobs'a
benzetiyorum Steven istaşlı hali diyorum
Apple diyorum salla müzik Aynı falan
e-ticarette
Google'da araştırma yaparken marka
üzerine bilgi Üniversitesi'nin marka
bölümü yüksek lisans programına denk
geldim
oraya kayıt yapma karar verdim oradan
kabul aldım bir yüksek lisansa başvurdum
yüksek lisansdan sonra satışım 3 kat
arttı benim Çünkü üniversitede
öğrendiğim teoriyi eve gelip hemen
pratiğe döküyordum ben
birkaç örnek vereyim mesela nörop
pazarlama dersine giriyorum Hoca diyor
ki insan duygularıyla karar verir insan
duygusal bir varlıktır ben hemen
gidiyorum açıklamaları Duygu'ya yönelik
değiştiriyordu
kullanıcı deneyimi dersine giriyorum
Hoca diyor ki siteniz basit olmalı
kullanıcı dostu olmalı ben hemen siteyi
basitleştiriyorum böyle böyle
işimi 3 kat arttırdım artık yüksek
lisanstan sonra
profesyonelliğe adım atıyoruz yeni bir
mağazaya geçiyoruz 3 kişilik ve ekipten
13 kişilik ve ekibe geçiyoruz önceden
fotoshopları fotoğraf çekmeleri ben
yapıyorum artık hepsini ayrı ayrı bir
ekip yapıyor
büyük hayallerim var üniversite bayağı
bir gaza getirmiş beni
vizyonun genişlemiş
festivaller düzenliyoruz
coğrafi bu coğrafyadaki müziği dünya
tanıtmak için etkinlikler düzenliyor
sosyal sorumluluk projeleri düzenliyor
fakat bir yandan da benim başka bir
derdim var Geldiğim yere doğduğum yere
herhangi bir katkıda bulunamıyorum ben
görmeme rağmen ekonomi çok kötü orada
istihdam yok sonra iyileşme yok burada
asgari ücret 3000 lira ise Orada
insanlar mecburen bin liraya
çalışabiliyorlar
başka çareleri Yok ben bunu görmemi
bilmeme rağmen Hiçbir şey yapmıyorum
orası için
Bu da benim bir yanımı çok acıtıyordu
böyle de bir hayalim var Yüksekova için
diyorum ki ben buradaki ustalarımı
götüreceğim yüksekova'ya
oradaki dezavantajlı gençleri yetiştirip
birer Usta haline getireceğim satışını
yaptım enstrümanları orada ürettireceğim
daha sonra
festivaller konserler ortaya yapılacak
daha sonra bunu doğuya yayıyorum en
sonunda Türkiye dünyanın enstrüman
merkezi haline getiriyorum böyle bir
hayalim var ama bunun için de hiçbir şey
yapmıyorum
bir gün bir ustamla konuşuyorduk Ustam
dedi ki Veysel ben köye gideceğim dedi
Doğan Usta Bu arada ismini de söyleyeyim
selam da gönderelim hadi Türkiye'nin en
büyük ilçelerinden biri kendisi
neden dedim Usta dedi ki annem babam
hasta dedi benim ve yaşlılar Köye gidip
Onlara bakmam gerekiyor
dağın ustayı kaybedeceğim için çok
üzülüyordum
Ben de ona yüksek o hayalimden bahsettim
dedim ki Doğan Usta böyle bir projem var
benim ama bunu yüksek böyle yapmak
zorunda değiliz gelsen bunu senin köyün
de Malatya'da yapalım dedim O da çok
heyecanlandı hemen kabul etti
projenin ismini de miras koyacağız
amacımız bunu Türkiye'ye miras olarak
bırakmak
o günün gazıyla Ben bankaya gittim salam
müziğin bankadaki bütün nakit parasını
çektim köy projesine aktardım
Bir yıl boyunca bir yandan
atölye yapılıyor bir yandan Doğan Usta
gençleri yetiştiriyor bir yandan da biz
malzeme alıyoruz Bir yılın sonunda köy
atölye tamamlandı
Ben heyecanlıyım Doğan Usta heyecanlı
çocuklar heyecanlı vizyonteledeki gibi
Köy halkı heyecanlı herkes bekliyor
sonradan öğrendik ki makinelerin
çalışması için trifaz elektrik altyapısı
gerekli Ben de hayatımda ilk defa
trifazeyi orada duydum sonra elektriymiş
trifaz elektrik altyapısı olmadığı için
çalıştıramadık mecburen kurumlara da
kurumları talepte bulunduk onlar da bir
iki yıl sürecek dediler başvurunuz 1-2
yıl bekleyemezdik İş başa düşmüştü
kendimizi çektik
Bayağı da maliyetliydi ama
bir
elektrik çektikten sonra herhangi bir
sorun olmadı artık bu kütüğü mesela çok
değerli bir enstrümana dönüştürüyoruz
hatta bunu zar zor kölelerin elinden
kurtardık yakacaklardı
enstrümanları yapıyoruz satıyoruz çok
güzel tepkiler alıyoruz Hatta bayağı bir
iyi fiyatlara satıyoruz
alan kişiler bir daha alıyor
gururlanıyoruz
Bu arada Karaköy'deki mağazamızda aşmış
oluyoruz
yayınlamak için orada
müşterileri ziyaret edip bakıyorlar
güzel tepkiler geliyor
her şey yolunda hem Üsküdar'da hem
Karaköy'de hem Malatya'da takibi bugün
doğan Usta beni arayana kadar Doğan
Usta'nın sesi titriyordu
bir şeylerin olduğunu farkındaydım ben
aklımda bin bir senaryo geçti birinin
öldüğünü düşündüm
Doğan ustayı konuşturmaya başardım köye
baraj geliyordu baraj bizim atölyeye de
kapsıyordu atölye yıkılacaktı bunu
duyduğum zaman ben dondum
bütün
emeklerimiz hayallerimiz solar altında
kalacaktı kabus zannettim Kendime
gelmeye çalıştım Araştırdık Evet
doğruuydu bizde atölyeyi mecburen
geçici olarak Üsküdar'daki mağazamızın
yanına taşıdık
Ama tabii ki vazgeçmedik
yüksekova'ya gidiyoruz oradaki çocukları
alan açıyoruz
hepimizin Bu Topraklara bir miras
bırakması gerektiğini düşünüyorum
Biz de bunun için çabalıyoruz çok
sevdiğim Ermeni sanatçı aram tigra'nın
çok değerli bulduğum bir sözü var
dünyaya bir daha gelirsem ne kadar tank
tüfekle silah varsa hepsini eritip
sadece zurna yapacağım sözü üzerine
Yüksekova'da memleketimde çok büyük bir
proje başlatıyoruz
oradaki çocukları yetiştirip bile Usta
haline getirip oradaki Tank ve tüfekleri
birer enstrümanına dönüştüreceğimizi
umut ediyorum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Bu arada o kız vardı ya Bir çocuğumuz
var
[Alkış]
nerede
ortalama orada ayağa kalktım çocuk da
orada
[Alkış]
çocuk çocuk da geliyor
[Müzik]
[Alkış]